this week marks one year since the world
health organization declared the
coronavirus pandemic
for medical experts it's been a year of
learning and adapting we've all been
doing that
as we fight the pandemic dr anthony
fauci from the national institutes of
health reflected on lessons learned in a
very challenging year
that is really a game changer for an
outbreak it would be so unusual
to have a respiratory disease of this
magnitude
in which such as a large percentage
is driven by people who have no symptoms
dr fauci is now focusing his attention
on covet variants that have become much
more prevalent
he says the best way to stop them from
developing themselves is for everyone to
get vaccinated
and not to relax restrictions too soon
you look at a state like texas that has
opened it up
for all intents and purposes when you
see that what's your reaction
uh it's dismay uh it's it's ill-advised
what you really want to do is
get the baseline very far down and then
gradually pull back
on the public health measures but to
just turn it on like a light switch and
turn it off
like a light switch is very risky
dr fauci says americans should not be
lulled into a false sense of security
and we all have to make sure
future surges are kept at a minimum